in Eastern Turkey I'm a northern city at
the death toll from Monday's earthquakes
continues to rise a few minutes ago
Turkish president
announced a dramatic jump in the number
of deaths in his country to 16
170 that takes the overall total on both
sides of the border with Syria to more
than nineteen thousand Hobbies beginning
to fade of finding more survivors under
the rubble but there is some small
optimism in Syria's Rebel areas in the
north aid from the United Nations has
started moving through the babal Hawa
Crossing for the first time since the
Quake struck
it is the first response after this
earthquake the Convoy consists of six
trucks loaded with sanitary materials
blankets and other items that will be
delivered to one of the organizations
that operates in the liberated areas an
organization that is a partner of the UN
in order to be delivered to our people
need in those areas
well for more let's bring in Brandon
Smith he's in his hand run in Turkey as
Mediterranean Coast Bennett let's talk
about this Aid delivery first of all um
one would imagine this is desperately
needed by people in Syria but one
wonders if it is going to be nearly
enough
foreign
desperately needed Aid and as they said
they're six trucks it barely scratches
the surface of what they need in Syria
in fact before that Aid arrived the head
of the Rescue Services in that part of
Syria uh said that there's no assistance
has come yet and we're waiting to see
they need heavy equipment the sort of
heavy equipment you can see behind me
here that is what they need they're not
getting it they there are digging with
shovels and buckets and their bare hands
to try and pull uh panpool people from
the rubble now more than four days after
the earthquake struck the problem as it
was always the case with Syria is
politics is getting in the way of the
rescue effort the uh Aid is only allowed
to cross from Turkey in to Syria there
are no other Crossings allowed there's a
U.N mandated Crossing Point turkey says
if the security situation prevails is
stable they'll open a couple of other
Crossing points but the Assad regime
only wants Aid Crossing front lines and
the reason a doesn't do that at the
moment because agencies people are
giving out a concern the Assad regime
will siphon off that a that's why before
the Quake It was crossing the border
from Turkey to Syria it stopped because
of the quake and it's only just started
again but nothing close to what they so
desperately need there Rob the meanwhile
of course the search and rescue
operations are carrying on not only
looking for people still under the
rubble but trying to help survivors as
well we can see some of the operations
going on behind you talk us through
what's happening Where You Are
so here in a scander on the city of a
quarter of a million people we want to
show you how where I'm standing looked
before to how it looks now we took this
off uh Street's view that shows you the
normal life just a few days ago taken by
the Google Google street maps before the
earthquake struck and how it looks now
I'm standing on the remains of those
buildings that you see in the picture
they have earlier on today managed to
pull uh three people alive out of the
building behind me that is why there is
they are still clinging onto hope here
every now and then work stops around me
here a whistle is blown and the call
goes out for absolute silence
because people think they may have heard
somebody deep underground in the
buildings there's a lot of nothing while
we've been here unfortunately but they
are still clinging to that hope the
problem is they've been so much
destruction and so much stress on the
facilities that the Turkish government
can provide that they can't get to every
building quickly and we walk past areas
where buildings are just completely
pancaked and if there's any chance of
finding people underneath it's just
taking a long time to get to them and
there are places where and now again I
think we're being asked we're actually
being asked to be quiet again so it's a
good opportunity just for me to hand
back you'll see all the hands going up
for the so for the moment Rob I'll I'll
keep quiet and I'll hand back to you
Brandon thank you very much indeed
that's burning Smith reporting to us
from iskandarin on turkey's
Mediterranean Coast where those searches
are still continuing
while the Turkish president has been
visiting affected areas regime about the
ones called for Unity after being
criticized but his government's response
to the disaster rescues like this one
are getting fewer in Tokyo more than 16
000 people have died there many remain
unaccounted for them Castle is joining
us now from the headquarters of the
disaster and Emergency Management
Authority in Ankara Cinema president
erdogan had promised housing and shelter
and financial support of course the
scale of that responses has to be
enormous to match the scale of the
disaster how is the government dealing
with all of this
well Rob presidents are done use the
word disaster of the century this is
what the seismologists also have been
saying that this earthquake these two
earthquakes that happened in the same
day in the same region hitting 10 cities
in Eastern Turkey is called as the
disaster of the century of course as you
said the impacts of it is enormous
because there have been 13.5 million
people living in those areas in those
cities it means all these people's lives
are directly affected some of them died
some of them survived some of them left
the city some of them have been put to
dormitories or hotels designated by the
government authorities for them to have
temporary accommodation but of course
there needs to be Capital all these
Investments That president erdon has
been mentioning since this morning like
uh completing the necessary replacement
of the housings in those area within one
year these are Big Investments these
require a lot of money as the government
will need to also compensate for this
because it's a natural disaster so
turkey will need more to do this and
this means a much more burden on the on
the country's budget of course
especially thinking that considering
that turkey has been going through a
fragile economic period within the last
two two and a half years with a fragile
currency depreciating against the US
dollar every day these are going to be
very very difficult tasks for the
government to be able to complete but of
course this is what he pledged and
trucia Was preparing for an election on
May 14 this would be a presidential
election and the general election that
would elect the deputies the members of
the parliament and president erdon still
wants this election to be held on the
very at the designated time but
everything needs planning everything
needs money and everything needs
investment about what we're talking
about and the search and rescue
operations are the first phase of this
post-earthquake process but following
that there will be a process of
normalizing life these will be also
requiring Investments so a long period
of work a difficult task is awaiting for
the Turkish government whether the
ruling act party stays in power or
another party comes to power but
everything will require more money and
this will mean more burden on the on the
government's budget at Syrian Cinema
Casio will bring us up to dates from
Ankara
well the rest Assad has got more from
Karma marash it was the epicenter of the
disaster
nearly a thousand of buildings have
collapsed here and hundreds of people
are dead right behind me you can't see
that the the the the heavy lifting
machines and the vehicles are still
digging into the rubbles and trying to
reach to the the bodies there so in the
last 24 hours unfortunately no one has
been taken out of the rubbles that you
can't see alive but we have seen several
dozens of people dead bodies were just
coming out and when they were taking out
the dead bodies they were covering them
with the with the blankets and trying to
to to to to to make at least the family
is comfortable because that disturbing
images were very much upsetting for the
families that have been waiting here for
almost more than 80 hours by now so you
have seen also several buddies that were
taken out from the Bravo were burned
because the fire also is still
continuing and the rescue team teams
haven't been able to have been able to
manage to to distinguish that as well so
you can see that the other buildings
that are standing around are heavily
damaged very much cracked so the the
rescue teams here needs to be
extraordinarily meticulously uh careful
there but still as I said they but time
by time periodically the work here is
stopping because the rescue team needs
to listen to the rubbles and they're
asking everybody to be to be quiet if
there is any voice any sound that comes
from under the under the rubbles
earthquake victims have been using
social media to reach out to emergency
crews for help it's hope that lives
could be saved because of messages
posted by those stuck in the rubble let
me call some Sharif reports
incredible rescues and desperate
searches for loved ones across turkey
and Syria
earthquake in turkey and helped Syria
became trending hashtags on social media
offering the world a window into efforts
to find survivors
but images from previous disasters and
other countries also filtered onto
timelines that led the Turkish
government to impose temporary
restrictions on Twitter on Wednesday
Ankara said the platform was being used
to spread disinformation some from fake
accounts but critics say the
restrictions hampered efforts to get
crucial Aid to people hours later after
a widespread public outcry access was
restored if you want to help personally
go to the sources of Turkish emergency
services and see how you can contribute
financially
Twitter has also been important for
those coordinating rescue efforts from
within the country and outside and it's
been used to offer help and mobilize Aid
this video of a young man trapped under
debris in the Turkish town of hate went
viral his pleas for help finally
answered
on the other side of the Border in Syria
calls for support have been equally loud
on social media platforms the volunteer
organization the white helmets operates
without the support of national
governments its members ask for Medical
Aid through communication apps and
social media
here in this place in Northwest Syria
after 38 hours so our elements are
working to rescue the people under the
rubble
no help has arrived from outside Syria
the people here
are saving their family and their
children with themselves as well as
supporting rescue relief operations
they're vital for those who've survived
earthquakes and need food and shelter
and where do they find it right here
Facebook Instagram Tick Tock you name it
social media is radically changing
disaster relief efforts